des ruines à perte de vue dans la région
de kharkiv la contre-offensive
ukrainienne a permis de libérer
plusieurs villages dévastés par la
guerre cette femme retourne chez elle
pour la première fois depuis l'expulsion
des soldats russes
[Musique]
donnent jamais je n'aurais imaginé une
telle chose
une telle agression
et tant de destructions
il n'y a plus rien
puisque je vais vivre mieux vivre parmi
les villages libérer les ukrainiens
disent avoir repris le contrôle de pitau
munich à moins de 30 km de la frontière
russe mais la reconquête est encore
fragile ici les habitants vivent sous le
feu des bombes la ligne de front n'est
qu'à quelques centaines de mètres
vous partez oui
l'état major ukrainiens assurent que les
russes ont dû se replier près de la
frontière pour ralentir la
contre-offensive menée par kiev mais aux
portes de kharkiv les soldats restent
sur leurs gardes dans leur retraite
les troupes russes ont posé des mines
sur le bord des routes oui or
nous sommes en train de gagner
bien sûr que l'ukraine y gagne ce que
nous faisons tout ce que nos soldats
font à marioupol chaque jour à marioupol
ou dans le donbass b to c acte courageux
ce sont des petites victoire dans la
grande guerre que nous menons
à plus de 400 kilomètres au sud les
soldats du craignant tiennent toujours
l'usinage opstal mais les russes ne
relâche pas la pression et continuent de
pilonner cette dernière poche de
résistance à marioupol